today on the matt well show why did the
city of new orleans put a giant
two-story tall hair pick right outside
city hall to honor juneteenth we'll
discuss also the washington post
profiles a young mother of twins in an
effort to prove why abortion is good and
necessary but they accidentally proved
the opposite feminist megan rappino has
a message for female athletes stop
complaining and just let males take over
your sport your sport uh that's girl
power for you i guess now plus the
airline industry comes up with a new and
horrifying way to make your flying
experience even more miserable in our
daily cancellation us uc irvine comes up
with a new inclusive spelling of the
word woman but then worries that it's
not inclusive enough story's so insane
you'll think i'm making it up but i
assure you i am not we'll talk about all
that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Music]
well you know as inflation continues
it's important to keep your budget and
financial goals top of mind um think
about the things you can do today that
come out ahead like for example
refinancing your mortgage if it's not on
your to-do list it should be because you
might be able to consolidate
high-interest debt into your home loan
which can offer hundreds of dollars
worth of monthly savings and i know just
the people to help it's american
financing they're a family-owned
mortgage lender that's known for its
custom home loans and it's no pressure
approach to lending uh they pride
themselves in doing whatever it takes to
set you up for financial success they
can help you save up to a thousand
dollars a month plus tens of thousands
long term and we could all use the
savings these days this may be an area
of savings you haven't thought about but
you really should why not learn more all
you got to do is call american financing
get a free no obligation mortgage review
right now and if you start soon you
could close in as little as 10 days and
that means the savings kick in right
away so call 866 569-4711
that's
866-569-4711 or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls
8182-334-nmlsconsumeraccess.org
well the results of a recent gallup
survey come as no surprise according to
the polling company belief in god has
ebbed to its lowest level on record in
the united states 81 now say they
believe in god this is down from what
would have been
close to 100 in the mid 20th century and
any time before that it's also down from
the 87 percent who believed in god only
five years ago but the biggest shift can
be seen in the youngest generation
survey generation tick tock with only 68
affirming the existence of any sort of
higher power now if you break this down
even further as many surveys have and
you investigate how many americans
identify themselves as traditionally
religious apart from simply believing in
god the numbers are even lower in 2020
american church membership dipped below
majority for the first time with 47
saying that they were members of a
church that number was 70 in 1999.
now these figures are significant
historically so
and they tell us quite a lot but here's
what they don't tell us
that americans have no religion
membership in an identification with
traditional theistic religions may be
declining precipitously but
there is something coming in to take its
place america in fact is still a deeply
religious country always has been is now
probably always will be
it's just that a different religion a
twisted shallow perverse and destructive
one has achieved cultural and
institutional dominance
in fact far from being an irreligious or
secular country we're actually living in
a theocracy of sorts right now
but our theocratic dictators belong to
the religion of leftism now like any
religion this one has its own holy days
of obligation we're living through of
course its most sacred observance of
pride month competing with it for
attention is the leftist religious
holiday that just passed which was
juneteenth which fell on sunday and then
was observed as a federal holiday on
monday supposedly the day is meant to
commemorate the abolition of slavery and
to celebrate freedom a worthy thing to
celebrate no doubt
but that's not really the intention of
those who advocate for this version of
the holiday neither was it the intention
of joe biden when he made it a federal
federal holiday last year now let's
recall that a year before that
on the campaign trail so in 2020 a year
before making it a federal holiday biden
didn't even know what juneteenth was
let's watch this again he's going down
at texas on juneteenth right
the first major massacre literally
speaking of
the
black wall street right years ago he's
gonna have a rally
he's gonna have a rally
and he doesn't wear a mask and he
doesn't think he's i mean come on
you know he's so unsure of himself he
keeps saying right that's what right
this is the right thing no wrong it's
not that's not what juneteenth is but of
course you know this this is actually
the um
the evolution of juneteenth and the
reason why it became a thing
is partly the blm riots but even more
than that it was because uh
donald trump was doing a rally
on june 19th
and uh someone in the media pointed out
that oh you know that's juneteenth
and then everyone in the country
pretended they knew what it was so that
they could blame trump for doing
something offensive for some reason by
having a rally on juneteenth and it was
at that moment that the left decided oh
this this is a thing now we're going to
make this a thing nationwide
12 months after that uh biden who had
never even heard of it but now 12 months
later decided that it was so deeply
meaningful
that it needs it needed to be federally
recognized
during his remarks for the signing of
the juneteenth national independence day
act
biden said that juneteenth is a quote
day in which we remember the moral stain
the terrible toll that slavery took on
the country and continues to take and
that we must quote learn from our
history and celebrate progress and
grapple with the distance we've come
but the distance we have to travel
so juneteenth is not so much a
celebration of freedom as it is an
opportunity to reflect on the moral
stain somehow shared by people who had
nothing to do with slavery at all
and it's also a time to dwell on the
supposed systemic injustice is still
visited upon black people by white
people
white guilt is the original sin of the
leftist religion it's really the only
sin as every other sin they recognized
always ties back to whiteness quote
unquote juneteenth then becomes like
maybe their version of good friday
a day of
atonement
and that is why
the media marked juneteenth this year
with talk of reparations
time magazine headline juneteenth is now
a national holiday our reparations next
many similar headlines were published
claiming that reparations must come next
it's the natural
next step after juneteenth
representative sheila jackson lee
attended a worship service at a church
in houston for juneteenth where she
called for exactly that reparations
listen
as the pastor said
it is time for the commission
to study slavery and develop reparation
proposals
so that we can heal the land and heal
the nation
i expect
that there will be
as it is understood no
snatching from someone else no one is
going to knock on your door and snatch
something that you have but the nation
will acknowledge
and be able to respond
to the challenge of this is bostick
that we all should learn we all should
read we all should have an equal
opportunity education and health care
that's what we want
the nation to respond
there's a systemic treatment
that has come that has caused a divide
there will be no snatching she says
we're not going to snatch anything
she perhaps hasn't noticed that there's
quite a lot of snatching going on in our
cities right now a lot was happening
during the blm riots
and uh that snatching was explicitly
justified as an act of reparations
although she did say
nobody's gonna knock on your door and
snatch something so maybe that's that's
the technicality here is that uh
generally when they do the snatching and
the looting they don't knock on the door
first they just walk in so i guess in a
way she's right
but that wasn't enough the reparations
of looting wasn't enough because in the
religion of leftism nothing is ever
actually enough
to wash away the white guilt and heal
the racial wounds
so now the nation must respond by giving
more free things to people like sheila
jackson lee who was never enslaved and
yet demands payment for sins committed
by long dead people against other long
dead people
this makes no sense until you understand
it properly as a religious claim
that's why there's no hint of patriotism
in the juneteenth celebrations
not patriotism for you know america at
any rate
the flags that adorned the juneteenth
google doodle were not american flags
but pan-african flags
and those in fact are the flags you see
flying for every june teen celebration
this is the flag that students in at
least one school
were forced to swear their allegiance to
in honor of juneteenth watch this
on the count of three
one
two three i pledge allegiance to the
flag of the afro-american people
under god i will protect freedom
[Music]
seek peace honor our ancestors and
encourage and support the development
and prosperity of people of african
descent you may be seated
now whatever a holiday actually
celebrating freedom and emancipation
could be
and it could be a wonderful wonderful
thing actually we know that because we
already have one it's called july 4th
and that's wonderful that's that's a
true patriotic celebration but whatever
else it could be it's not this
that's not what juneteenth as it has
been established now is about
the spirit of juneteenth is best
summarized by um molina abdullah who's
professor of pan-african studies at cal
state in la and she tweeted this
attention white people please don't ask
if you can come to the cookout
juneteenth is freedom day for black
folks it should be reparations day for
white folks
right
racial division hierarchy
this is an important aspect of a leftist
religion
not a day for everyone she says
certainly not a time for everyone to
join in the festivities you leperous
white people must stay hidden away
wallowing in your guilt
while superior races of people can just
party on without you
the most crucial thing to remember about
this religion is that it is
fully by design
destructive and ugly
the religions that it supplants tend to
strive for joy and beauty but not the
religion of leftism which is why it
prowls the country looking for beautiful
priceless monuments and statues and
works of art to topple and then replaces
them with nothing or else even worse
replaces them with something so hideous
and absurd as to seem like some kind of
practical joke now that was the case
down in new orleans where the statue of
john mcdonough was torn down in 2020 and
finally replaced this weekend
by i'm not kidding or making this up
a statue of a gigantic two-story hair
pick
again not a joke you can see it for
yourself at least not an intentional
joke anyway
nor is this meant to be a tribute to uh
spaceballs as many people thought maybe
it was it's not even that
the mayor of new orleans on saturday
proudly unveiled a 25 foot tall steel
afro pick
with a black power fist at the top
perhaps now that they're making
monuments out of random toiletry items
next we'll get a 50 foot high can of
right guard aerosol deodorant maybe eric
adams in new york will consider
replacing the statue of liberty with
like a giant toothbrush
at least that would promote dental
hygiene
i'm not sure what the hell this
gargantuan afro pick is supposed to
represent or promote
now i say that rhetorically of course i
know what it represents
it represents the hideous emptiness at
the core of the leftist religion
they can tear down and destroy and
destabilize but when it comes time to
build something of their own
this is what they come up with
okay they have no actual ideas about
anything
they just know what they
hate they don't know what they love they
don't know what they want
they're not building beautiful
masterfully made monuments to more
political more politically acceptable
historical figures that's not what's
happening
and that's partly because at this point
there really are no politically
acceptable historical figures maybe
somebody like
harriet tubman or frederick douglass
might seem like safe choices but we can
be relatively certain that um even those
historical figures would have had some
pretty problematic views about some
things
say about like homosexuality or
transgenderism
if anybody ever asked them
so the left they have no heroes to
champion except maybe george floyd karl
marx those are two guys
but more than that the reason they don't
replace a beautiful statue with a
different but equally beautiful statue
is that beauty is one of the things they
seek to destroy
this is what happens when you make a
religion out of nihilism
everything becomes ugly
it's also no coincidence that the pride
flag
which was gaudy and ridiculous looking
to begin with has just gotten uglier and
uglier as each with each successive
pride month
a religion out of nihilism and of
ugliness out of self-worship and
narcissism
a religion out of your most base and
shallow and degraded impulses
when you do that you end up with a
decaying culture
child drag queens
racial animosity turned into a holiday
and you also end up with some things
that maybe you wouldn't expect
like
giant hair products outside of city hall
but all of this
is part of the religion
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
life happens fast and it can end even
faster you might picture yourself living
to a ripe old age but it doesn't always
work out that way and if it doesn't
you're going to want to have a plan in
place otherwise the state people you
hate the people who are trying to
indoctrinate your kids take your guns
steal your freedom
they're gonna step in and take control
of your assets when you're gone they're
gonna determine what legacy you leave
behind so don't let the state decide
what happens to your children should
something happen to you and that could
happen at any moment instead take five
minutes and set up a will through epic
will starting at just 119 you choose who
raises your kids and you choose who gets
all of your useless dumb crap after
you're gone here's what i want to do um
here's what i want you to do rather go
to epicwheel.com and use promo code wall
she'll get a 10 discount on epic wheels
complete will package that yes can take
only five minutes to set up many of our
families at daily wire are now protected
thanks to epic will why don't you do the
same just go to epicwheel.com it's very
simple enter promo code walsh and do
something for you and your family today
so i want to start with this we have
here an article from the washington post
written by caroline kitchener
that really lays the pro-abortion
position to bear i think there's no
dancing around the subject here not
really anyway abortion kills babies and
uh that's a good thing according to
pro-aborts because babies are bad and
that's that's the position
laid out in this washington post piece
through the profile of a young mother of
twins and the headline is
this texas teen wanted an abortion
she now has twins
and accompanying the headline is a
picture of um as you can see two
adorable
little twin babies and
we're supposed to to see this picture
and immediately think how sad it is
that
those babies exist
and are alive rather than dead and
dismembered and rotting away somewhere
this is an actual headline the
washington post with pictures of of
little twin babies that says well now
look what you did pro-lifers now these
babies exist
um that's what caroline kitchener of the
washington post wants us to think anyway
when we see infant baby so let's get to
the article
it doesn't get any better in the article
itself um so read me through a little
bit she says
she writes brooke alexander turned off
her breast pump at 604 pm
and brought two fresh bottles of milk
over to the bed where her
three-month-old twins lay flat on their
backs red face and crying
running on four hours of sleep the 18
year old tried to feed both babies at
once holding kendall in her arms while
she tried to get olivia to feed herself
her bottle propped up by a pillow but
the bottle kept slipping and the babies
kept wailing and brook's boyfriend billy
high wouldn't be home for another five
hours
please fussy girl brooke whispered she
peeked outside the room just big enough
for a full-size mattress and realized
she had she had barely seen the sun all
day the windows were covered by blankets
pinned up with thumbtacks keep the room
cool brook raleigh ventured into the
rest of the house billy's dad had taken
them in when
her mom kicked them out and she didn't
want to get in his way
brooke found out she was pregnant late
on the night of august 29th two days
before the texas heartbeat act uh
heartbeat act banned abortions once an
ultrasound could detect cardiac activity
around six weeks of pregnancy it was the
most restrictive abortion law to take
affect the united states in nearly 50
years now
if you're pro-life meaning that you you
love and appreciate life
and you think life is a good thing right
then you
you hear the first part of this this
profile
and you might think that this will turn
into a story of like a young mother who
was prevented from from killing her two
children
and though she now has financial
hardship she also is experiencing the
beauty of motherhood and um and of her
children and she's grateful to have them
and she's learning to embrace this new
and unexpected reality of motherhood
and like that's that's all a good a good
thing
you know that's the way you you might
see this as a pro-lifer
but this story is coming to us from a
death worshiping nihilist so it kind of
takes another direction and it continues
texas offers a glimpse of what much of
the country would face if the supreme
court overturns roe v wade this summer
as has been widely expected if the
landmark precedent falls roughly half
the states in the country are expected
to dramatically restrict abortion or ban
it all together creating vast abortion
deserts that will push many into
parenthood
sometimes brooke imagined her life if
she hadn't gotten pregnant and if texas
hadn't banned abortion just days after
she decided that she wanted one she
would have been in school rushing from
class to her shift to texas roadhouse
eyes on a real estate license that would
finally get her out of corpus christi
she pictured an apartment in austin
enough money to trip for a trip to
hawaii where she would swim with
dolphins and water so clear she could
see her toes
now from there
we're told the whole story
of how she got pregnant then tried to
get in for an abortion before the law
took effect but she couldn't
so then she went for an ultrasound she
was hoping the baby wouldn't have a
heartbeat but then it turned out that
the baby did and in fact there were two
of them so now she has two daughters
and then we get passages like this
if it wasn't for the texas law brooke
knew she might not be standing here
she'd probably be studying for her next
exam while billy mastered some new trick
on the quarter pipe she liked to think
that they'd still be together spending
their money on movie tickets and
whataburger instead of diapers and baby
wipes
now
of course the life of a mother of two
beautiful children
is far more meaningful and interesting
and important
than just like hanging out at a fast
food restaurant
so it almost seems like this is supposed
to be a pro-life story right
especially when we're told actually
later on in the in the article it goes
on
for quite a while we're told that um
that brooke married the father of her
her children so she did the right thing
she married
the father and they formed a nuclear
family and that she loves her babies
and she's she's happy to have them now
and we're also told that she doesn't
want to think about what would have
happened without the texas law because
she knows that they probably wouldn't be
here if it wasn't for that law
okay and all of that is in the article
and yet the writer
makes her feelings known in the headline
and also by the fact that she's an
abortion reporter for the washington
post and she's not shy about her
pro-abortion radicalism she retweets uh
planned parenthood all the time so she's
a an advocate for abortion
and yet it just kind of goes to show
that
even when writing this profile again the
writer caroline kitchener
made her intentions clear
this is supposed to be a sad story
about a woman whose life was destroyed
by the presence of two beautiful uh
babies
and yet you read through the entire
article and you're kind of left thinking
well but is this supposed to be pro-life
because
it it's it sounds like and you know this
pregnancy was an unexpected turn and she
didn't want the pregnancy at first but
now she has the babies and she's
grateful to have them and she's living a
more meaningful life and yeah there are
more challenges now but she's she has
resolve and she's getting past it
and so that's that's a positive thing
right
and now these two uh beautiful babies
are are living whereas before they
whereas they wouldn't have been living
before
and it shows that really any honest
discussion of
the issue ends up sounding pro-life even
if it isn't supposed to be
if you're just honest
and you and you tell a story
and it's even if it's we're supposed to
take a pro-abortion message away from it
we don't
because that's where honesty on the
subject of abortion always points to the
pro-life message
and that's especially the case with this
article here all right this is from cnn
uh jennifer lopez and her child m
maribel munez 14 are being praised for a
recent duet but not because of the music
the pair took the stage recently at the
la dodger's blue diamond gala
lopez introduced m using the
gender-neutral pronouns they and them
lopez said in a video the last time we
performed together was in a big stadium
like this and i ask them to sing with me
all the time and they won't
so this is a very special occasion they
are very very busy
and pricey
they cost me when they come out but
they're worth every single penny because
they're my favorite duet partner of all
time she's talking about her child this
whole time of the day her individual
these are not twins this is just one
person
so jennifer lopez is the latest
celebrity with a with a non-binary child
all the celebrities have non-binary
children now
they used to be adopting you know the
trend among celebrities used to be uh
that they would all adopt chinese babies
as a fashion statement and now they're
all transiting their own kids as fashion
statements
but it is it's so transparent
um what what's what they're doing that
this becomes a trend
and then what do you know the trend
setters in hollywood they all discover
magically that they happen to have
non-binary and trans kids
how do you explain that scientifically
if this is all a natural scientific
phenomenon
you know none of this is social
contagion none of this this is not a
trend at all
oh nobody would choose to be trans
nobody would choose to be non-binary
nobody would choose this for their kid
that's not happening
well then then why is it so common why
is it every celebrity now has a kid like
this
is something in the water in california
makes no sense at all except as this is
a fashion statement and these are people
who parade their kids around as fashion
accessories
and uh it's really as simple as that
on a similar topic this is from the
daily wire says soccer superstar and
political activist megan rapinoe
argued in an interview published sunday
that female athletes and their parents
need to suck it up over advantages
biologically male transgender athletes
might have over girls
now keep in mind megan rapinoe
yeah a couple things keep in mind about
her first of all
she's a viscerally repulsive uh
unlikable person so that's the first
thing
also she's supposed to be a feminist
hero and champion she's supposed to be a
champion for women's rights and all the
girl power stuff
so remember that as we read through here
and also remember that the um and i ever
every time we read anything about megan
rapino i always have to remind you
because it's so great that the women's
olympic soccer team the women's world
champion soccer team lost to a group of
15 year old boys in a scrimmage a few
years ago
so
if um
if if men were to fully invade women's
soccer
megan rapinoe and all of her teammates
they would all be out on their asses
there would be no place for any of them
because they would be totally dominated
as they were totally dominated by just
by adolescent uh kids
in spite of that we continue
the um
soccer star told time magazine she is
100 supportive of trans inclusion in
girl sports dismissing concerns about
fairness while emphasizing that people
need to understand that sports is not
the most important thing in life
uh rapido also inc argued that
high-level sports are all about
regulation which the athlete apparently
believes can erase trans athlete's
advantages quote i would also encourage
everyone out there who is afraid
someone's going to have an unfair
advantage over their kid
to really take a step back and think
what we're actually talking about here
we're talking about people's lives
i'm sorry your kid's high school
volleyball team just isn't that
important
and i think people also need to
understand that sports is not the most
important thing in life right
life is the most important thing in life
we're talking about kids we're talking
about people's lives we're talking about
the entire state government coming down
on one child in some states three
children in some states
this of course as you might expect makes
no sense at all
if it's just sports and sports aren't
that important
and it's just a volleyball team as she
says
then why can't we say that to the quote
unquote trans kid
the male who's identifying as a female
so what you're saying is it's just
sports okay let me let me try to work
through this here
it's just spoiled let's take the
volleyball example okay hypothetically
it's just volleyball it's just your it's
just a volleyball who cares
and yet
if a male who identifies as a female
is not allowed to compete against the
females in this volleyball team that's
just a volleyball team and it's just
sports that will be a threat to his life
his life depends on being able to
compete against female volleyball
players
and yet it's just a sport it doesn't
matter
does that make any sense at all
why can't we flip this around
is my question
so megan rapinoe the feminist
girl power champion
is saying to female athletes uh it's
just it's just sports who cares you get
your opportunities stolen
uh get over it
it's really not that important
why can't we say that to the trans
person
the trend the transporter says oh i
really want to compete against females
well it's just sports who cares get over
it
my life depends on it no your life
doesn't depend on it actually you'll be
fine
go compete against the men i don't want
to compete against men okay then don't
then don't compete against anybody it's
just sports
so we're not taking your life from we're
not killing you
we're just saying you can't compete
against women because you're not one
oh my feelings are hurt well they get
over it
your feelings aren't that important so
you can say that to every girl on the
team you can say to them your feelings
just aren't that important sorry
and if they start complaining about you
can laugh in their face so why can't we
do that to the trans people then
that's what you're doing to the women
why can't we why can't i do that to them
because in that in that case i think
it's much more appropriate
um when you've got
one person
trying to make making a claim
[Music]
and trying to impose themselves on
a whole group of people
and intrude in a place where they don't
belong
you know and and we have both groups now
and one group is an entire group and the
other group is just one person
but both groups are saying that their
feelings will be hurt among other things
if uh if if the other person gets their
way
we have to turn to one group or the
other and say
your feelings just aren't that important
here that's not the primary concern here
one group or the other we have to say
that too
one group or the other has to get the
hard message
so are we gonna say to all the girls
your feelings don't matter
or are we gonna say that to that one guy
i am more than happy to say to the one
guy
your feelings just aren't that important
here it's not the most important thing
in fact um
fairness is more important
preserving female sports in the
integrative field of sports is more
important than your feelings
but more important than all of that is
is simply the truth the basic truth
that's the most important thing of all
and your feelings are not more important
than the truth they're not more
important nobody's feelings are more
important than the truth
and of course everything that i'm saying
right now is seen as horrifically cruel
and transphobic and media matters is
gonna take and they're gonna clip it and
put it on on
on twitter which is fine
but if i was saying all of this about
all the girl athletes in the country get
over it your feelings don't matter just
just just stop whining
nobody that would be fine that would be
a perfectly acceptable message
that's what doesn't make any sense
all right we have another moment of
lucidity from camila harris here talking
to joy reid and i want you to listen
when you're listening to this listen for
something in particular
keep in mind as you listen
that camila harris
never knows
what the next word she's going to say
will be until she says it
okay so when she's speaking you can and
you can hear it in her voice you can see
it in the blank look in her eyes the
kind of almost panicked look she gives
every time she's asked any question at
all
she never she says a word and she
doesn't know what the next word is going
to be
and she doesn't know where the sentence
is going to end until it ends
and once you realize that it all starts
to make sense let's listen
we all sat and watched the katanji brown
jackson uh hearings
in which she
very calmly um sat through
what i think a lot of particularly black
women let's just be honest felt was
brazen disrespect from senators like
lindsey graham senators like tom cotton
senators like josh hawley
what did you think when you watched that
hearing
i will tell you
joy
i experienced great
joy
when i watched this brilliant
phenomenal
black woman
jurist
be so smart
and just cut through the political
gamesmanship
that they were attempting to
incite
and she just was composed
and as far as i'm concerned was taking a
whole lot of people to school
and i watched that with incredible joy
because it was just brilliance
being displayed
for the entire country to see and i
cannot wait to see if that will only be
matched by the joy
that i experience
when i see her take the oath
to be the next justice on the united
states supreme court you know i told you
she has no idea what she's going to say
what the next word is going to be when i
was a kid i don't know if other people
play this game i don't know if we
invented this game or not but when i was
a kid we used to play this game
uh me and my siblings in uh in the car
on on long car trips and i'm sure it
tortured my parents but
and the game was that you know one one
person would say a word
and then the next person had to say a
word
and one by one you'd build a sentence
but the goal was that you couldn't be
the one to end the sentence
so your word had to make sense in the
context as it's being built but you had
to keep extending the sentence that was
the game
we were a bunch of nerds these are the
kinds of games we played and that's
basically what camille harris is doing
with herself in her own brain every time
she speaks
you could see it there i
will tell you
i
experience
great
joy
when i watch this
brilliant
black
woman
jurist she keeps there's a question you
know there's also a question mark at the
end of every word she says
it's amazing
and this is the this is going to be
their hope in 2024 is what you just saw
there
or maybe not uh we have this from the
daily wires there's a new poll revealed
that the majority of the american public
wants a fresh face in the oval office
and not a recycling of president biden
or former president trump
biden will be uh two weeks shy of 82
years old by the time of the november
2024 elections trump will be 78 years
old a june 10th yahoo poll found a
whopping 64 percent of respondents
felt biden should not run for
re-election in 2024
only 21 thought that he should run again
while 15 could not decide which side to
take
of course
across the board it did not matter whom
the poll surveyed all groups wound up
with roughly the same percentages of
respondents agreeing biden should not
run 66 of women 62 percent of men 65
percent of those ages 18 to 29 i mean
this is just a total disaster for the
democrats um the only group that was
somewhat less hostile to biden running
again were african-american respondents
among whom 49 thought that he should not
run
um
and uh let's see
again it says the uh the yahoo uh yougov
poll found that 55 percent of
respondents felt trump so here's the
trump numbers 55 percent of respondents
felt trump trump should not run for
reelection in 2024 31 thought that he
should run again while 14 could not
decide
which uh side to take
i don't i never understand that i don't
know people and why do you even bother
to think two categories i don't
understand the people that actually take
these polls i don't understand it but
then the people who take them and then
just say i don't know
hey we want to survey you about this
okay sure and then every single question
you asked was like i don't know i don't
know
i'm gonna take this survey but i have no
opinions about anything but i'll still
take your survey
so
trump fares a little bit better but not
much better 55 say they don't want him
to run for re-election
and uh this is
because you know it turns out that
there are a lot of people in the country
this is a country with a population of
330 million
not counting all the illegals
who maybe we're getting to a point where
even they'll be able to be able to run
for for election and so there are a lot
of people
and it's just really hard for me to
believe
that the only and best qualified
candidates
are in their late 70s and early 80s
okay that that can't be the case if
that's the case then we are we're just
doomed we we might as well not have any
more presidential elections we might
just just
close up shop
there's no hope for us
if it's actually the case that the two
best potential candidates
are respectively 78 years old and 82
years old and there's nobody younger
than that
who should have a chance then we're done
i mean the baby boomer generation they
have been hanging on to the reigns of
power
desperately for decades and they won't
let go
and i guess they would tell us that's
because uh
nobody younger is
qualified
which means that they've failed as a
generation to raise the next generation
that's one of your most
basic duties as a generation is to raise
up the next generation so you're saying
you've totally failed in that regard
but if that's true then there's just
there's simply no no point no hope at
all
uh but i'm not quite willing to accept
that yet
i i think that there are some people
shy of
say their 70th birthday who maybe should
get a shot at this thing i don't know
just a thought
all right here's the new york post that
says delays canceled flights and being
stuck in the middle seat may no longer
be people's biggest air travel concerns
a new possibility awaits double decker
style airplane seats for coach
just like the bus one row is above
another with the top level reached by
the stairs you can see the picture there
okay this is what they're talking about
the designer alejandro nunez vincente
has come up with this plan and uh i
guess he's pitching this to
air airlines
and so this is they call this double
deck and you think of a double-decker
plane and they used to have those
you know like back in the early days of
commercial airline they had double
decker planes these huge planes but now
this is not really double decker these
are um
on the same level of the plane
but you
you know you would if you're on the
lower level your face would be directly
up against somebody's rear end basically
they are trying to find ways to make the
airplane experience even worse
every moment that's
that's what they want to do i mean this
is now they want to put somebody's ass
directly in your face
they figure i guess you can't smell the
farts well enough on planes already so
they want to fix that problem
and now you'll be able to smell you know
the guy in front of you who's eating the
burrito bowl you can smell his his lunch
on on both ends i suppose
it is kind of amazing that
the airline industry
is the one industry maybe not the only
one but one of the major ones
where they're constantly thinking of
ways to make their services even more
miserable and unpleasant
and i'll never get over the fact that
airplanes have somehow declined in
quality over the past 50 years
okay how is that possible how has it
gotten worse how has air travel gotten
worse in the last half century
i mean it's safer okay so you're less
likely to crash into the side of a
mountain which is nice that's not
nothing
but the trade-off is that you'll want to
crash into the side of a mountain
because of how terrible the experience
people 50 years ago you know i mean they
would they dress up to get on the planes
and it was just night these
no matter where you sat on the plane you
had a lot of room a lot of space they
serve you full five course dinners and
everything
and they were thinking
based on what air travel is today they
were thinking 50 years from now
we're all going to be flying through the
sky at lightning speed in our own
personal flying
spas
with a with a robot servant waiting on
us
but instead we're packed in like slaves
on a galley ship
our face is directly in the firing line
of another passenger's butt
with three inches of leg room
chained to the seats
forced to flap our arms out the window
to keep the plane in the sky
that's what it's like in coach anyway
which is why i just fly first class to
avoid all of that uh not to brag but
first class is so much better that's one
of the things in life that's totally
worth the investment so i recommend it
for everyone
you know with the ever increasing
numbers of car makes and models it's
impossible to stock all the parts you
need in a traditional chain storefront
why indoor often pointless or even
intimidating questions about the
specifications of your vehicle uh only
to have the counterman order the parts
on his computer anyway first you walk in
the cameraman is intimidating you with
questions doesn't even have what you
need you're traumatized you're sad you
run out in tears you're shaking and it's
happening all the time every time i go
to autozone it happens you have
computers with access to rockauto.com at
home and in your pocket rockcotter.com
is a family business serving auto parts
customers online for 20 years go to
rockauto.com to shop for auto and body
parts from hundreds of manufacturers the
rockauto.com catalog is unique and
remarkably easy to navigate quickly see
all the parts available for your vehicle
and choose the brand specifications and
prices you prefer best of all prices at
rockauto.com are reliably low and
they're the same for everybody why spend
up to twice as much for the same parts
no reason to do that amazing selection
reliably low prices all the parts your
car will ever need
rockauto.com go to rockauto.com right
now see all the parts available for your
car or truck write walsh in their how
did you hear about us box so they know
that i sent you let's get to our
comment section
says only matt would title his episode
is sanity making a comeback and then in
the episode his answer is no
well that's
i'm always honest though give me that
jb says matt i have a serious question
for you as a supporter what are why are
humans special please answer without any
reference to god and without
self-referencing humans and the fact
that you are one
why are we objectively special
okay well i don't know if i agree with
the uh
parameters you put in place here i mean
the fact that i'm a human is indeed one
of the reasons why i prefer humans
because i do prefer my own species is
that irrational i mean
i value and
prefer and protect my own family over
other people's families is that what
about that
so i would call this kind of sort of
species chauvinism
completely natural and good and
necessary even
and that's even without any objective
reason to justify it but i do have
objective reasons what makes humans
special over other species in the known
universe well we build civilizations
we also destroy them but we do build
them
we have language we have art and science
and music
we tell stories
right we're rational creatures some more
than others but we are by our nature
rational
we are aware of ourselves and the
universe and uh
we can contemplate what all of this
means
so what makes us special i mean
literally everything about us
is special and distinct from
all the animal species
would be my answer
uh let's see taylor says your wife
tweeted that your oldest son had an
accident and got stitches was she really
talking about you matt be honest no not
not in this case my son did get stitches
um
a real coming of age moment kind of a
rite of passage
and i was kind of proud of him for
needing stitches i think that's an
important part of boyhood at some point
you need to get the stitches so now he's
getting a little bit competitive about
his injury
and yesterday he tried to tell me that
his injury probably hurt more than when
i tore my achilles so he's constantly
going around bragging now about how bad
the injury was and how much it hurts
compared to other people's injuries
and i said no first of all mine was
worse
and i didn't even cry when i got injured
unlike you
i respond that way to my son because
he's nine and i'm seven apparently
um
funk soul bubby says i'm not into my
birthday either but one year i told my
mother that it didn't mean anything to
me and she responded it does to me so
that put it into perspective that's
actually a good point that is a good
perspective um
but i think
i'm glad your mom said that because this
i think i agree that actually the
parents are the ones who should get
gifts on a kid's birthday
my kids should be giving gifts to me on
their birthday
because because i'll tell you why
the fact that you survived another year
even if just barely is my achievement
it's not yours if i left it up to you
you would have been dead 50 times over
so
i i said yesterday that it's not an
achievement to live another year but
when you have little kids it's an
achievement on the part of the parents
so i kind of like that
i don't need to celebrate my own
birthday but i should get to celebrate
my kids birthdays
i and i'm the one who's who's celebrated
on those birthdays i like that okay
um and prince vegeta says hi matt so i
noticed you now have 1.1 million
subscribers congrats by the way how soon
should we expect the interpretive dance
be patient my sweet baby be patient
all will be revealed
in time
and that's a tease right there that's
what that's called in the business
over the weekend swimming's world
governing body voted to ban biological
males from competing in women's swimming
competitions we talked about it uh
yesterday is sanity finally making a
comeback well i already told you the
answer is no but here's the good thing
at least biological reality seems worthy
of discussion again thanks in no small
part to my groundbreaking documentary
what is a woman it's the most talked
about documentary in america and has now
surpassed over 5 000 ratings on rotten
tomatoes with an audience score of 98.
what is a woman is also soon to be the
best-selling book that you can pick up
now on amazon or wherever books are sold
big things are happening here at daily
wire it's never been a better time to
become a member with your support we're
not only affecting real change in the
culture but creating new alternatives to
broken institutions we're building the
future we want to see and your
membership helps us get there all the
faster you can see this uh in the fact
that both what is a woman and tara on
the prairie are in the top five most
popular movies at home on rotten
tomatoes right now plus a membership
gets you access to our entire library um
our entire library of content including
what is a woman tara on the prairie as
well as other documentaries like
choosing death the legacy of roe fouche
unmasked ben shapiro show debunked
exclusive articles and so much more so
head to dailywire.com subscribe to join
us today that's dailywire.com subscribe
right now now let's get to our daily
cancellation
[Music]
you know the biggest challenge with
today's daily cancellation will be
convincing you that i'm not making any
of this up
but it shouldn't take much convincing
because you ought to know by now that
it's impossible to invent a form of
leftist insanity that leftists
themselves have not already come up with
and even if i did dream up some new
brand of lunacy on my own we could still
be sure that some leftist somewhere has
already thought of it or will soon think
of it
and when they do think of it they will
take this thing that i said as a joke
and turn it into their mission and their
identity in life
with all that in mind we head over to uc
irvine and their women's center for
success
as their page on uc irvine's website
explains the women's center for success
quote advances gender equity by raising
consciousness on social justice concepts
fostering personal growth building
community connections encouraging
identity development and increasing
access to resources that support
holistic wellness
one important thing to note here is that
women's is spelled
w-o-m-x-n
now as you know the way to make things
inclusive uh it's been decided is to
stick a random x into the middle of them
x marks the woke as pirates used to say
obviously you know if you want to make a
word inclusive the best way to do that
is to arbitrarily change it so as to
make it unpronounceable that's how you
make it inclusive
but is there another more coherent
reason to spell women with an ex
well as aaron cebarium a reporter at the
washington free beacon pointed out on
twitter uc irvine has a whole page
dedicated to explaining the value of the
letter x and also grappling with the
challenges that it presents
their page with the heading why women
with an x explains the following quote
women is one of a few lexical and social
phenomena including the adoption of x in
naming gender non-conforming individuals
gender queer folks two-spirit people
femmes transgender folks and non-binary
people
now please note that folks is spelled
f-o-l-x-s
so that it'd be properly pronounced i
guess foxes
we have to pronounce words like gollum
now in the name of inclusion so it
continues
women with an x acknowledges that gender
identity exists in a sphere and one word
has room for multiple gender expressions
without weighing one more important than
the other in addition it highlights that
more than one gender expression can be
impacted by patriarchy misogyny and
sexism
this term recognizes that in the past
the history of feminism has included
racism transphobia and harmful gender
binary views
all of this is accomplished somehow with
the letter x
but is it as simple as that
can we just plop that x into the middle
of a word and then go about our day
peace with peace of mind
confident that everyone has been
included
well not so fast
because this actually real page on a
real website for a real college
university in the united states of
america in 2022
continues on for many more paragraphs
discussing the importance and
implication of the word x when it's
placed uh the letter x rather when it's
placed randomly into words for no
discernible reason and then it gets to
the caveats and the exceptions of the
potential problems which are numerous
we're told this
it's important to note that not every
single person prefers to use the x
identity is personal and is influenced
by lived experiences
what matters most is that we take into
consideration each person's own
preferences and respect the ways in
which they choose to identify
they could be using the spelling with
the x or not and both preferences are
valid
okay so you see that
you can't just spell women with an x you
must first conduct a survey of every
single person who might potentially read
the word that you're about to write and
find out if they prefer it
based on their lived experiences to have
the x or not have the x
but what happens if some preferred and
some don't prefer it
and what if some have other preferences
maybe there's a person who's lived
experience has led them to prefer that
women is spelled with a z in place of
the x
maybe somebody's lived experience
demands that every letter in the word
women is replaced with a series of
random symbols and numbers
i for one am traumatized if women is not
spelled w q 33z question mark 5
exclamation point
if i see it spelled any other way i'll
vomit and cry and
immediately stab the nearest person in
the throat
i can't be blamed for this
my lived experience is what it is so
does this mean that you
simply cannot spell the word or indeed
any word at all
as soon as the word exists in one form
spelled one way then it no longer
potentially exists in any other form
spelled any other way which makes it by
its nature non-inclusive
the only truly inclusive word is that
which is not written at all once it's
written it is taken on a certain form
and if it's in that form then it can't
be in any other form
so best then to avoid writing any words
but will that be enough
no it turns out
because even if words are not written
they're still spoken
and that too can be non-inclusive
so going back to this i must remind you
totally real page on a totally real
college's real website we are told this
quote
by being still new to the mainstream
there is not one particular
pronunciation of this word
most pronounce it like they are saying
women or woman
but spell the singular and plural with
the ex
however
this raises the question if that
actually is truly inclusive
members of the blind community may be
left out if there's no audible way for
them to hear this distinction
others prefer to say it as weminx or
wuma x
or wumux
these ways can bring attention to wimxin
when take when talking verbally to
someone about and opens up more dialogue
about linguistics
now um
you might think that the one advantage
to being blind is that you're spared
this kind of thing but the uber woke
will not let the visually impaired off
the hook so easily they too must be
wrapped up in this
they must be given the experience of
hearing women pronounced womanx
it wouldn't be fair if they were
deprived of the opportunity to hear
human beings speaking like your gps when
it's trying to pronounce a city with a
multi-syllabic name
but this raises questions also
uh
what about deaf people
yes they can see the name but they're
not able to hear it being pronounced
and what about people who are both blind
and deaf
after all the work that helen keller did
how can we exclude members of her
community
what about those who are in a coma what
about members of the coma community
the fact is that you you can't write
this word or any word without excluding
people
and you can't speak the word or any word
without excluding people in truth you
cannot do say or think anything without
engaging in ruthless exclusion
just consider this
every time you do say or think anything
at all
you are excluding in that moment all of
the things you are not doing saying or
thinking and thus all of the people who
would prefer it if you were doing saying
or thinking all of the things that you
are not does that make sense
to simply exist and go about your day
and interact with the world and
communicate in any form and certainly to
develop your own unique view of the
world and opinion about things is to
exclude
worse it is to discriminate
it is to choose in every moment one path
instead of any other
exclusion and discrimination are
elemental inherent aspects of life on
planet earth
so then what should we do
well i think we have two options
either
we can stop obsessively trying to
include everybody all the time in
everything and just go about our lives
as normal human beings
as human beings always have
or
in the name of inclusion we can all
launch ourselves collectively into space
um not in a rocket ship but individually
into space itself
where there is no sound no light no
gravity no oxygen
nothing at all but the formless
shapeless endless abyss
into which we can all tumble eternally
until we are consumed by it
and our bodies are ripped apart by the
vacuum
and we are all reduced to nothingness
only then
when we are all nothing
and nothing is everything and everything
is nothing
only then
will everyone truly be included
so that's option b
and i think something we should
seriously consider for a number of
reasons
but until then uc irvine is today we
must say cancelled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo vadowsky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire 20
22.
germany is restarting its coal plants
because environmentalism is a big hoax
the buzz lightyear movie flops at the
box office after a gay toy kiss
and we celebrate on this show
not just juneteenth but june 20th and
june 21st as well check it out on the
michael knowles show